but there's plenty of places where the
patriarchy which is not a word i tend to
use
does not protect women at all or very
well and one of one of those places is
[Music]
another boy i heard from um
uh is with what's happening now with
regard to our apparent inability to
understand what women are which is thus
allowing
men
to claim they're women and to beat women
in sports which is a much you know it's
it's it's both important and not nearly
as important as the fact that once you
have that then you start letting men
into women's prisons and uh and you know
and everywhere else like all the
dominoes fall so wait wait let's be
clear about that okay the problem here
so first of all i'm not a believer in
the patriarchy i believe that there is a
patriarchal force but the patriarchy is
a made-up fiction that cannot exist
because it doesn't make sense for a
male to
gang up on female given that the
majority in fact the huge majority of
everybody's genome doesn't know in the
next round whether it's going to be male
or female but i heard
i heard that the reason
get into it yeah
i know there's this there's this crazy
you know this but for our audience
there's this insane and apparently taken
seriously in some circles uh theory over
in i don't even know what
fill-in-the-blank studies
that argues that the reason that humans
are sexually dimorphic sexually seized
dimorphic which is to say men are on
average bigger than women
we all know this um
is because historically
men were
constantly stealing food from women and
thus women were starving which caused
them to be smaller and the smaller women
did a better job of surviving because
they didn't need as much but that's only
because the men were always stealing
food from them
right
so so actually i don't say this very
often but i can't even right but
but the point is this is like somebody
starts with the human case and they've
never thought about the other cases in
nature because there's dimorphism of
both directions right
you know in eagles the female is bigger
yeah raptors tend to have female and and
uh many many herps actually many of the
many amphibians and reptiles females are
larger in part because they tend to be
oviparous and they're carrying the eggs
on their body and they need a bigger
structure in general to to do that and
uh dick alexander my advisor
made a compelling case that animals that
compete in three dimensions rather than
two
males are selected for agility rather
than uh force that's cool but um but
let's take the the basic underlying
logic of dimorphism
in monogamous species
what you tend to get are individuals of
the same size right that's the
basic case
as
males have the potential to have more
mates
there is a priority put on their being
able to displace each other which then
causes them to be distorted to be pushed
off the ecologically optimum size for
whatever the creature in question is
towards larger size they accept a cost
in order to be able to displace each
other for sex which frankly also has
this consequence of making them fragile
right so males are bigger in many
species they are stronger and they are
shorter lived and only part of that is
because they're asking people to hold
their beer and then doing stupid [ __ ]
that gets them killed but the but to
hold my beer while i do this stupid [ __ ]
that might get me killed is also
sexually selected right exactly it is
sexually selective so you i thought you
were i would i would have included
a fourth word in there you said bigger
stronger
shorter lived bigger stronger
in general in non-sexual reverse species
um the more
this will be more true the more
poliginous the species
stronger
bigger stronger showier showier
mean the tale
or the dance or the song
or the car or you know any number of
things well and in humans you have two
kinds of showier right you've got
show-offs who tend to be male and you've
got females who are
physically augmented in a way that
advertises the presence of resources
of the kind that are necessary for a
woman to be fertile and produce
offspring
and you know these things are
monitored by
uh by the two sexes
um but anyway the again the overarching
message is this is the very special
human case of something so impossibly
long-standing and so
um central that every time selection
produces the two different size gametes
it produces
variations on the same pattern it's
nothing to do with people right and so
the idea that a you know a generation of
people is going to forget
um the obvious and start engaging in
sophistry and gotcha-ism
right
it's like well you know so historians um
like to complain and i think correctly
um that history isn't being taught that
we don't know our history that lots of
people don't know the relevant things
from history and so of course we will
end up making the same errors over and
over again and one of the things that is
true of evolution at least you know the
the branch to which we have referred
here but it's not the branch that we are
mostly in so macroevolution as opposed
to microevolution um is that it is an
historical science um and it uses many
of the same um
it has to use the same kind of inference
as history does and you know history
because that is defined as sort of
post-literate and therefore in general
there will be texts you're still using
what people thought about or claimed to
think about it at the time but in
historical science which is to say
macroevolution or geology also has to
use inference has to use indirect
mechanisms methods by which to assess
what actually happened
yeah uh it has it's left with no choice
because um the uh
well you can't experiment on the time
machine large scale patterns
all right no but with regard to mac
revolution because they're because we
don't have a time machine we just can't
go back and know first that's what i
mean you can't you can't run the
experiment right you can you can create
uh you know speciation events in
very
rapidly accelerated critters but you
can't figure out you know
how how birds evolve that way you have
to go back to fossils in which a lot of
the the evidence has been erased by by
time
[Music]